c'est pas simple de massacrer des gens
c'est une tâche difficile physiquement
et mentalement je crois pas que les gens
réalisent
on a besoin d'évacuer
vous savez il y en a plein d'autres
comme moi vous croyez
il y à 40 ans votre fbi a été fondée
pour traquer john dillinger
aujourd'hui nous devons faire face à des
actes d'une extrême violence entre
parfait étranger
on traverse le pays pour enseigner aux
flics les techniques du fbi va vous
embêter une petite minute
elle a été retrouvé menotté et attaché
au lit c'est fou ce que les gens peuvent
s'infliger une recule devant aucune
erreur
comment peut-on vous aider on devrait
utiliser toutes nos ressources
interroger les personnes les plus calés
dans les domaines les plus variés net
hon criminels ou est ce qu'on le devient
les psychopathes sont convaincus d'être
tout à fait normaux ils sont donc
quasiment impossible à étudier mais vous
avez trouvé une méthode s'approchant de
la perfection bonjour mesdames c'est ce
qui rend tout cela si passionnant et
potentiellement significatifs j'arrive à
comprendre ces hommes débit la façon
dont il voit le sexe et les femmes on
n'est pas là pour sympathiser avec eux
on est là pour les électrocuter on ne
peut pas aimer tout ce qu'on fait on
traite avec des tueurs en série et tueur
en série c'est le nouveau terme je te
préviens ton attitude va te porter la
poisse
si j'ai une pour détruire la vie des
gens qu'est ce que tu as fait votre
comportement va vous porter préjudice à
jean forte si vous partez je ne pourrais
pas vous aider il n'existe pas de règle
pour s'adresser correctement à ces gens
si on veut que ça marche il faut parler
à davantage de sujets vous voulez
trouver des trucs
alors va falloir se salir avec les ports
comment lutter contre les fonctions ne
sais pas comment les fous fonctionne
[Musique]